Dr. Zakai, thank you so much for the
good work of dawa you have been doing.
My question is why don't we go to do the
dawa to the church? Why don't we go to
do the dawa to the churches and temples?
Because
>> why don't we do dawa by going to the
churches and temple?
>> Yes, correct. Because like today most of
the whole we are all Muslim. We know
about the we know about our beloved
prophet. We are all aware about the
Islam religion and Islam means
delivering the message to the
non-Muslims. That's my question.
>> Why don't we brother said why don't you
go to churches and temples and do dawa.
I have done that a lot. I have gone to
many churches and many temples. Now what
I'm doing I want you also to go to
Jenna. I want you to become D. I'm
training the Muslim doa because Allah
says I have to speak to the non-Muslims
as well as Muslims. So I call both of
them. Here the people of Mombasa are not
very close to the Muslim. See not a
single non-Muslim sister. In Nigeria
there were many. So the problem is
people of Mombasa.
You should call the non-Muslims here.
Even if you call the non-Muslim then
don't do dava. YOU'RE DOING DAVA
INDIRECTLY.
So the problem is in the Muslims of
Mombasa.
Very few non-Muslims came. Who's to
blame? Not Dr. Zakai. The people of
Mombasa. How many non-Muslims you got
here brother? Mashallah. You translated
five. You'll get saw. You know all of
them who gave Shada you'll get part sab
inshallah. Full.
>> Alhamdulillah.
>> How many non-Muslims you called your
brother?
>> I invited a lot of them.
>> How many came?
>> None of them.
>> Oh, all got scared of you.
>> No, no, no. scared of you or God scared
of me
>> because you know Islam is not about just
forwarding the message and calling
non-Christian to come and have such
talks in in this hall. So my suggestion
was why don't we go to them like make an
invite in a temple or like today's a
Sunday
>> but when we go to temple all these
brothers will not be there correct I've
already gone many a times when I started
dhawa I've been to many temples I've
been to many church now when we are
showing live there are h millions of
non-muslims watching they are not here
but they're watching on the channel do
you know that so which is better
millions of non-Muslim watching on the
channel or I going to the temple and
speaking to 10 20 non-Muslim which is
better
>> the channel one
>> correct we used to do that earlier you
know when we were beginners and I
started doing dawa I used to go to many
priests many churches many temples a lot
of dava now we have reached maybe Allah
has given me better opportunity but you
should continue going to the church till
you don't come on the stage you go to
the church go to the temple do dawa
When Allah gives you bigger audience
then you do where you get more sab
correct
>> correct now people are coming here there
are few thousand people here and very
few non-Muslim no problem but on the
channel there are millions watching tens
of million out of which millions are
non-Muslim so our main purpose should be
how many non-Muslim do you reach
our main intention should be convey the
message we can give shada to Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala that We conveyed the
message to as many people as we could.
Hope that answers the question.